Just don't!
You fucking spaz out...
...like you got--
[Mark laughs]
(Goddammit!)
You have like a seizure every time you start playing...
...it's just like: OHYEAH, there's so many buttons...
...even though I play PC games.
Oooooh, that's-- okay, now...
...everyone back up a step!
Cause this is gonna be goood!
Yeah, this-- just cut out the last 10 minutes of you...
...trying to do a simple thing.
[Mark laughs]
[Bob laughs]
SHUT. UP.
I don't wanna hear it!
"Oh, god!"
HE'SNOTDOINGIT!!!
[Bob can't handle it]
Oh, you missed, but--
WOAH!
Holy crap! What is that?
Woahwoahwoahwoah!
How did you do that?
(Excuse me.)
WOOOOOO-OH-OHOHOH-OHMYGOD!
Yeah, no, I got an idea!
Schwump.
[Mark laughs]
Grrrh!
Roll down the mountain!
Go, go, go, GO! Yes! Go, go, go, go! Little more!
Go! Ah! Get it! Getitgetit, gogogo!
OH, you're so close!
[skater gracefully tumbling]
All right, that wasn't as-- oh, go, go!
Gogogogogo!
Goddammit.
Ahh.
Woo. Wee. God--
[Mark laughs]
Son of--
I mean, I guess that was like a 30 foot fall.
Good eye, bro!
"Ah, god dang it!"
That was exactly 30 feet again. Hooray!
Don't instant the replay, watch this!
I wanna instant replay ten times!
[both laugh]
What the hell happened?
God dang it! All right...
What was that?
[siren of failure]
Oh, sick ...and then just jump off the top?
Yeah!
For no valid reason in... to... regards to skateboarding.
The end is...
"Jump off the top of the building..."
The end is just a montage of us as like...
♪♫...and I believe♪♫ ... oh
What the fuck was I singing?
♪♫And I believe I can fly♪♫
You're singing like a Cher song [mumbles song titles]
- ♪♫Do you believe that I can fly?♪♫
- Yeah, that was it!
[laughing]
All right, we're gonna have get Daniel...
...to make a mash-up of...
...Cher's "I believe in life after love"...
...and "I believe I can fly".
And can that be your theme song?
That will be... my theme song, yes.
♪♫Duhduhduh - it's Bob!♪♫
...and then also...
♪♫I do believe I can fly!♪♫
...anything, cut to a splash screen of...
...like a Looney Tunes background...
...and I just like [thumbs-up]...
...and that song starts playing...
...cause that makes sense.
- Go back to where you were. Nononononono...
- Over here? Over here?
...go backbackbackbackbackbackbackbackback.
Ah, I saw the ramp, I'm going the right way.
Oookay...
- I-- I was only
- Oh, you're going, okay...
[Bob laughs]
[Mark laughs like a goofy seal]
Thanks for...
[Bob laughs]
Can we just do that?
[trying to make a laugh-choir]
That can... that can go on the official...
...Markiplier Laughtrack CD™.
Doors! [fart]
God damn! L-lemme in!
[Mark laughs]
...then your wife can cheat on you...
...then I can drown all my children in the pool.
Huh-hoh-hoh-hoh-ho.
drown all my children
dRoWn AlL mY cH-dRoWn AlL mY cHiLdReN
DrOwN aLl My Ch-DrOwN aLl My ChIlDrEn
drown all my children
Cause apparently that's what people do...
...when they play The Sims.
"Oh my god!"
Every Sims video I've ever seen is always like...
...okay, uhm, we've got our family, uh, today...
...I wanna show you an exploit...
...if you build a pool and have a pool party...
...and then uninstall the ladder...
...everyone... [they start to laugh]
...everyone drowns in your pool.
It's hillarious!
It's like... it's like in the beginning of...
...the most monotone let's play, like...
..."all right, okay"...
..."and then EVERYBODY DROWNS!"
It is! It's just like every [mumbles]
Marker, marker! Put a marker down!
I am so way ahead of you!
Okaay.
So why are all the ramps off the side...
...to other parts of the park?
Obviously, I wanna kill myself, video game!
What's the point?!
[You use the seal force, Luke!]
- Only if It's that laugh...
- Oh, that's what you were doing the first time!
Only if it's that laughtrack.
You're making like a... seal ...
[both imitating seals]
I have really good impressions of lots of youtubers.
Huh. Okay, gimme CaptainSparklez first.
"Oh, yeah. That's good.
Oh yeah, this is CaptainSparklez."
Pewdiepie.
[imitates Pewdiepie]
Uh, who else... who else do I have?
"Hello everyone, this is Yamimash here."
Huh...
"We're gonna play... Pokémon Emerald Green..."
No, no, you're not doing that right.
"...XY..."
Not doing that right.
HeLlo EvERyboDY, THiS iS YamIMaSH.
I WelCOmE yOu To PoKéMon!
[Bob laughs]
WiNgArDiUm ...okay, I'm not gonna...
I'm sorry, all my British fans, I greatly apologize for that!
Boom!
[Mark laughs like a goofy seal again]
[The spin of Death]
Woah-oh-hoho!
[they laugh together]
[they ech together]
[sudden realization of the vague sexual undertone
of eching together]
Bye everybody!
[laughing]
I should've taken a pee.
Like, ten minutes in I was like... oh, it's so bad.
[outro music]